acheter du rouble pour avoir notre gaz
voilà la réponse de Vladimir Poutine
pour contrer les sanctions
internationales désormais les pays
auteurs de ces sanctions pourront
acheter du gaz russe mais uniquement
dans la monnaie
russea
raciste
Vladimir Poutine espère ainsi tirer
parti de la dépendance en pétrole et en
gaz russe des pays de l'Union européenne
pour contrer les sanctions imposées par
la communauté internationale d'après
gastrom 58% de ses ventes de gaz se font
actuellement en euros et 39% en dollars
américains
va ainsi devoir modifier ses contrats ce
que dénonce plusieurs pays au premier
rang desquels l'Allemagne traite
dépendant du gaz russe depuis l'invasion
de l'Ukraine par la Russie le rouble a
perdu environ 20% de sa valeur mais
quelques heures après le discours de
l'animé Poutine la courbe est repartie à
la hausse atteignant sont plus haut
depuis l'instauration des sanctions
parallèlement en Europe les prix du gaz
ont eux bondit de 30%. l'Union
européenne veut réduire de deux tiers
dès cette année ça dépendances en
énergie fossile avec la Russie pour son
affranchir dès 2027 l'annonce de
Vladimir Poutine pourrait accélérer
cette transition